Well, here's how I solved it--this windmill has access to 1000 W of power, but it loses 400 W,
so that means the usable amount of power is the difference, 600 W.
Well, power is work over time and what's our time going to be
if we're looking for how many kilograms of water we're going to move.
Our time is going to be one day and when you do it at the unit conversion,
you find that one day is equal to 86,400 seconds.
We can solve this equation for the total work this windmill can do,
multiplying both sides by 86,400 and we get a rather huge number of 51,840,000 joules.
So this is the work that can be done in a single day
and this work is just equal to the mass of water times (g) times (h)
because we've already shown that when we lift an object,
and it doesn't matter if that object is a stone or water by a height (h),
this is the work that we have to do.
Well, we know (g) and we know (h), if we solve this equation for (m),
we find that our windmill can move a total of 864,000 kg of water per day.
Now that we know this number, deciding on how many windmills to build,
just depends on figuring out how quickly water is leaking in.
Now, we've made some assumptions here and these are assumptions
that I encourage you to talk about in the forums, but for now, I'd like to say, congratulations!